we are more than a week now into the
governor's stay-at-home 2.0 advisory and
as you just heard there
his office is looking at ways to stop
the spread of coronavirus
if things don't improve while we don't
know what that will look like
it is a cause for concern among some
small businesses
sasha loft is live tonight with how
they're feeling
sasha
denise and brian i spoke to the owner of
a small local boutique tonight
she says this year has been devastating
with local restrictions related to cov19
and she says the idea of another
shutdown would just
really be tough especially for her and
those everyone else who relies on the
local economy
it has been horrible jessica boone
shares the struggle she's faced as a
small business owner
in the age of covid19 there are days
when we don't have a single person walk
through the doors
and it's scary she's managed to keep her
west valley boutique in business so far
but with talks of another potential
shutdown she's concerned
for the future it's hard to hear that
i'm not essential
when it's my livelihood this is how it
helps support my family in the next
two weeks the governor has encouraged
nevadans to stay home
citing a resurgence in coronavirus case
numbers
e-7 health ceo dr jonathan bhaktari says
his team
has seen a concerning uptick we've been
seeing both
an uptick in testing and we've been
seeing an uptick in positive results
especially among younger people he says
more activity leads to more risk so it's
crucial
for us all to take precautions the more
parties you go to the more people you
interact with
it's strictly a numbers game you're
going to be at more risk and jessica
encourages
everyone to stay healthy so she can keep
her doors
safely open it's hard to see the big
places who
will definitely live through this and so
many of our
local small businesses might not make it
jessica also has an online component to
her store she said she will fall back on
that if she absolutely has to but of
course
relies on that money from in-store
purchases
she says she does limit capacity because
of kovid 19 of course
encourage sanitization and hand washing
she sanitizes her store multiple times a
day
and requires masks for now reporting
live sasha loftis
8 news now